I want to show you this picture this is
the only path forward right here
everyone take a look that's it I'm just
kidding this is this is so I pulled up
some AI images that I made because I
think they're funny but uh look at this
guy's hat like this one guy over here is
wearing a very very tiny hat for some
reason this is a mid-journey made this
it's a generalissimo trump but uh I want
to show you another image this is uh
what the establishment fears Donald
Trump shaking hands with Sonic the
Hedgehog but uh this one is actually the
one I I want you to see because
if if you were to actually if you remove
Sonic the Hedgehog from this image it
actually looks like a real photo of
Donald Trump running down the street
there's the the average person's not
gonna be able to understand that this
was generated by AI
granted we put Sonic the Hedgehog in it
so we know this is not real this is what
I'm talking about with the with the
political battle that's that's coming on
uh coming up
this next year the Deep fakes that we
are going to see of audio a video it's
it's
No No One's Gonna know what's real